mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
bonjour je vous propose qu'on démarre la
réunion parce qu'à 15 heures il ya des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
donc nous si nos échanges s'allongent un
peu il faut il faut démarrer bien
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le conseil européen s'est réunie le 24
et les 24 et 25 juin dernier je remercie
le ministre de venir en rendre compte
devant notre commission selon nos
nouvelles habitudes
monsieur le ministre vous nous présente
très certainement les deux faces de ce
sommet européen
l'une qui était consacré à la situation
intérieure et un téléphone qui sonne à
la situation intérieure de l'union
l'autre à ses relations extérieures sur
le volet intérieur cette réunion a
naturellement été consacre son consacrer
prioritairement à la situation sanitaire
et à la mise en oeuvre du plan de
relance sur ce sujet je partage la
satisfaction du conseil européen devant
l'amélioration globale de la situation
épidémiologique en europe qui permet de
rétablir progressivement la liberté de
circulation malgré l'appel à une réponse
coordonnée face aux variants je constate
que la demande allemande m'imposer une
quarantaine à tous les voyageurs
provenant de zones où ce variant circule
activement n'est pas clairement
satisfaites par les conclusions du
conseil européen pourrait vous nous dire
pourquoi la france compte-t-elle
appliquer la même quarantaine que
l'allemagne aux voyageurs susceptibles
d'apporter le variant delta cette
question n'est pas anodine car nous
devons absolument nous prémunir contre
une quatrième vague
autre sujet d'inquiétude quand le
certificat vert sera-t-il lui
opérationnel j'ai pu échanger avant-hier
avec une parlementaire allemande venue
au sénat pour une réunion en forme à
weimar et helm indiqué que son pass
numérique attestant de sa vaccination
n'avait pas été reconnue à l'entrée en
france du côté du plan de relance les
progrès sont aussi à saluer près de la
moitié des plans nationaux pour la
reprise et la résilience ont validé par
la commission européenne
pouvez vous nous confirmer la date des
premiers versements à venir
je pense que tout ça se clarifie il
serait préoccupant qu'interviennent des
décaissements au profit de la hongrie de
la pologne qui ont parallèlement porté
le mécanisme
conditionnalité état de droit devant la
cour de justice de lieux celle ci ne se
prononcera pas avant l'automne
c'est à dire que ces états membres
recevront des fonds d'ici là sans
conditions quelle que soit l'évolution
de l'état de droit sur leur sol
l'actualité à budapest fait en effet
craindre de nouvelles dérives
dernier sujet intérieur à l'union
européenne qui fut abordée lors du
sommet de la zone euro qui a suivi le
conseil européen l'achèvement de l'union
bancaire sur ce sujet j'ai relevé les
propos très allant du président de la
république qui a appelé à accélérer le
calendrier de l'union bancaire et
l'union des marchés de capitaux
c'est un sujet très sensible je l'avais
d'ailleurs évoqué dans notre petite
réunion de travail sur la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe si mes souvenirs
sont bons ou sur la psf eu lieu sur la
paye est furieux et
voilà donc c'était un sujet qui revient
qui revient dans l'actualité
nous ne devons pas nous précipiter vers
un mécanisme européen de garantie des
dépôts sans harmonisés au préalable les
fonds de garantie au niveau national et
sans revoir la situation des banques
potentiellement déficitaires comme on
l'a d'ailleurs fait à la mise en place
de la supervision unique
en effet nous devons préserver les
banques françaises du poids de la
défaillance éventuelle d'autres banques
européennes au risque sinon de
fragiliser notre système bancaire est
finalement notre souveraineté pour
assurer nous mêmes le financement de
notre économie notre commission a
justement adopté la semaine dernière un
avis politique attirant l'attention des
autorités européennes sur cet enjeu
majeur
êtes vous également sensibilisés j'avais
noté d'ailleurs de l'an dans la réunion
qu'on avait fait part que ce sujet
n'était pas de votre part monsieur le
ministre
le sujet n'était pas forcément sexy pour
parler d'europe
mais finalement on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que c'est un sujet qui est
assez assez prégnant et en tout cas avec
des conséquences sur le futur
non non anodine sur le volet extérieur
le conseil européen a d'abord traité des
migrations
sur ce sujet les états membres ne sont
pas encore en mesure de convenir d'une
solidarité entre eux pour mutualiser les
forts d'accueil des migrants
mais ils se sont mis d'accord pour
demander à la commission de finalisée à
l'automne des plans d'action envers les
pays d'origine et de transit
ils ont aussi rejeté toute tentative de
pays tiers d'instrumentaliser des
migrants à des fins politiques
ceci n'est pas sans évoquer certaines
attitudes qui a pu notamment à voir la
turquie dans un récent passé toutefois
l'apaisement actuelle que l'on constate
en méditerranée orientale a favorisé des
conclusions plutôt positive du conseil
européen au sujet de la turquie qui
s'est vu promettre par la commission une
nouvelle enveloppe de 3 milliards
d'euros de l'union pour soutenir l'accès
des migrants à l'emploi la dénonciation
de l'instrumentalisation politique des
migrations vise aussi sans doute le
maroc après la crise 2
ceuta avec l'espagne en particulier mais
elle pourrait aussi viser la biélorussie
qui laisse grossir les flux de migrants
sa frontière avec la lituanie
les sénateurs paul o'neill j'ai
rencontré hier considère que cet afflux
ne serait pas possible sans la
complicité de la russie cette attitude
s'ajoutent aux provocations multiples de
la russie envers l'union et ses membres
ces derniers temps et l'on peut donc
s'interroger légitimement sur
l'initiative franco allemande lors du
conseil européen de proposé d'inviter
vladimir poutine à un sommet avec lui
sans doute s'agissait-il de positionner
le en interlocuteur de l'algue de la
russie au même titre avec la russie au
même titre que le président byden pardon
mais comment pouvait-on espérer rallier
les 27 à une telle proposition
assurément le dialogue doit se
poursuivre avec la russie c'est ce que
j'ai dit à nos collègues du sénat
polonais hier un peu pris de court sur
sur la soul est un peu pris de court sur
la proposition qui avait été faite
d'invitation mais je peux vous dire
qu'ils étaient est effectivement très
très en colère et pourquoi lui offrir
cette solennité qui dérange légitimement
nos voisins de l'est et qui ne
conduirait finalement qu'à afficher les
divisions entre les états membres au
bénéfice final de la russie le président
macro et la chancelière merkel ont
d'ailleurs fait marche arrière
hier dans l'après midi mais nous restons
dans l'incompréhension face à l'erreur
stratégique qu'ils ont commise pourrez
vous nous donner des éléments
d'explication sur ce sujet sans être
complet mon propos liminaires et déjà
très long aussi monsieur le mini jeux
vous cède la parole sans plus tarder
nous laisserons nos collègues vous poser
des questions ensuite
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
suis heureux de revenir devant votre
commission pour rendre compte selon la
tradition est désormais établie de ce
sommet européen qui avait suivi nous
avions l'occasion d'en parler un sommet
extraordinaire à la fin du mois de mai
et ce sommet ordinaire et non pas par
son ordre du jour mais par sa récurrence
et a été l'objet vous l'avez indiqué
d'un menu copieux notamment sur les
sujets internationaux je vais essayer de
revenir sur les principaux messages et
les principaux dossiers qui ont été
évoqués cette occasion par ordre
d'apparition à l'écran si je puis dire
je donnerais évidemment la priorité à la
question sanitaire qui a été évoqué le
jeudi après midi par les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement dans un contexte très
différent des précédents débats puisque
la situation par tout en europe
s'améliore nettement permettant des
réouvertures comparable dans nos pays
depuis le début du mois de mai mais la
tonalité a été celle d'un optimisme
vigilants car nous savons aussi là dès
le développement du variant dit delta
pose à nouveau la question de la lutte
contre la pandémie de sa maîtrise même
si la vaccination nous le savons est je
le rappelle ici solennellement est notre
meilleure arme et son accélération notre
meilleur outil contre le pro de la
propagation de ce variant et il faut
être extrêmement clair sur ce sujet ce
qu'on regarde le bilan qui a été fait
lors de ce sommet européen on voit que
les taux de vaccination ont
significativement progressé depuis le
début du printemps dans tous les pays
européens
il ya quelques exceptions mais notamment
grâce au cadre d'achats communs le taux
de vaccination sont assez comparables
d'un pays de l'union européenne à
l'autre et en moyenne dans l'union
européenne on a aujourd'hui 60 % des
adultes qui ont reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin et 40% de la population adulte
complètement vaccinés en france on est
un peu au dessus de cette moyenne avec à
la fin du mois de juin
hier pour donner le dernier chiffre 62%
des personnes adultes vaccinés 50 % de
la population totale qui a au moins une
dose de vaccin c'est cela qui a permis
aussi et cela était rapidement révoqué
par les chefs d'état de gouvernement et
c'est un point d'actualité puisque ce
pass sanitaires se met en place au
niveau européen complètement à partir de
demain j'espère que ça réglera les
difficultés qui ont été encore identifié
ces derniers jours et que vous avez
évoqué ce certificat numérique il
il permet en faisant la preuve d'une
vaccination ou d'un test car je précise
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un certificat
vaccinale mais un certificat sanitaire
comme nous avions l'occasion de
l'évoquer il permet de retrouver plus de
mobilité en europe avec prudence comme
je viens de l'indiquer
il ne s'agit pas encore d'une libre
circulation au sens qu'on ne vérifierait
pas la situation sanitaire de tel ou tel
voyageurs qu'ils soient européens ou un
touristes circulant sur notre espace
européen
je crois que c'est important et nous
suivons évidemment puisque j'ai évoqué
le variant delta
la situation humanitaire y compris de
nos partenaires européens je pense par
exemple au portugal mais pour l'instant
cela n'a pas nécessité de mesures
haddock ou de mesures supplémentaires et
nous avons nous mêmes
du côté français transformé notre
certificat sanitaire si je puis dire au
format européen
depuis vendredi dernier le jour même du
conseil européen et j'espère que le
premier jouer tous les partenaires
européens conformément au règlement qui
l'imposent seront en mesure de vérifier
de lire le certificat sanitaire commun
même si je précise qui parfois une
confusion sur ce point il ya un délai de
six semaines qui est accordée aux états
européens qui le souhaiteraient ce n'est
pas le cas de la france mais certains
l'ont souhaité comme l'allemagne pour
garder un format nationale qui n'est pas
forcément le format européen pour leurs
propres ressortissants
mais l'obligation c'est bien en tout cas
de pouvoir reconnaître le certificat
donc un voyageur français qui seront
dans n'importe quel pays de l'union
peine doit pouvoir avoir son certificat
au format européen reconnu lui pour
permettre l'entrée sur le territoire
je précise parce que cela était un
message porté par le train de la
république
que dans cette optique de vigilance
nécessaire maintenu le président comme
la chancelière merkel d'ailleurs a
beaucoup insisté sur la nécessité d'être
prudent la liste des vaccins que nous
reconnaissons comme vous le savez le
règlement européen oblige à reconnaître
les quatre vaccins qui ont été approuvés
et scientifiquement par notre agence
comme une agence européenne des
médicaments et que nous utilisons en
france exclusivement mais laisse aux
états membres la possibilité d'ajouter
pour l'entrée sur leur propre territoire
et seulement sur la propre territoire la
reconnaissance d'autres vaccins et
quelques pays 3 ma connaissance
aujourd'hui le font pour des vaccins qui
sont reconnus par le msc le vaccin à
sinovac ou même pas reconnus par le ms
je pense évidemment aux vaccins russe
spoutnik c'est lequel la hongrie qui
l'avait utilisé pour sa propre
population c'est le cas de la grèce et
c'est le cas de l'espagne à cette date
le président comme la chancelière glg
ont beaucoup insisté sur la nécessité
même si c'est une possibilité offerte
juridiquement que l'on s'en tienne le
plus longtemps possible à la liste
agréée par le m&a et seulement 7 6 donc
les quatre vaccins que j'évoquais
pourquoi parce que c'est d'abord ça
permet de le restreindre les flux et de
restreindre les flux d'entrée à ceux qui
ont un vaccin dont on est sûr de la
bonne qualité de la protection par une
appréciation politique c'est une
précision scientifique faire par notre
agence européenne commune et il serait
difficile d'expliquer aux citoyens
français que l'on n'utilise pas ces
vaccins parce qu'on les incidents les
estime insuffisamment protecteur mais
qu'on laisse rentrer des gens sur notre
territoire sur la base de cette
vaccination à ce vaccin là si tu peux me
permettre de secondes monsieur min sur
ce sujet effectivement tout et si
novak ne seraient pas reconnus dans la
liste mais comment se fait-il que
spoutnik n'est pas encore été réellement
évaluer par l' agence européenne alors
que alors que nos vaccins français
européens dits européens l'ont été
finalement dans des temps record
alors européen ou pas seulement européen
puisque américains aussi mais il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
de jugement politique sur ce sujet là je
ne suis pas le l'auteur des évaluations
mais ce que nous dit l'agencé européenne
des médicaments aux autorités françaises
comme à toutes celles qui posent la
question c'est que ce quick est
dépositaire du dossier bon les déposants
du dossier pardon ont mis beaucoup de
temps à livrer l'ensemble des
informations qui ne sont pas toutes
transmise et c'était une autorisation
qui aura pu être prête en juin c'était
l'estimation je crois que j'avais évoqué
lé fond votre commission d'ailleurs que
nous avions sur une base effectivement
indicative mais la documentation
scientifique nécessaires n'ayant pas été
fourni insuffisamment pas dans les temps
ça se prolonge
il n'y a aucun pour être très clair il
ya aucune volonté dilatoire politique ou
scientifique
mais il ya une expertise qui doit se
fonder sur le maximum de documents
possible comme ça a été demandé pour les
autres vaccins et c'est l'estimation
puisque là aussi c'est une procédure
scientifique c'est que ce ne sera pas
autorisée avant le mois de septembre
je précise quand même parce que je sais
qu'il ya eu des débats ou des polémiques
sur ce vaccin spoutnik que quand bien
même il serait autorisé rapidement
peut-être que sera-t-il ici mois de
septembre il faut qu'ils soient produits
et les quelques pays européens on sait
qu'ils ont fait appel aux vaccins
skotnik il y en a deux en fait la
hongrie et la slovaquie la hongrie la
guinée manière assez significative dans
le cas d'un accord bilatéral mais
minoritaire néanmoins par rapport au
vaccin autres livrets dans le cadre
européen
mais la slovaquie par exemple la fin a
passé un contrat de 2 millions de doses
il en a reçu à cette date que 200 milles
et de manière générale j'en profite pour
le signaler quand on compare les
politiques vaccinales géo politique
vaccinale de l'europe et d'autres
grandes puissances
les russes ont livré 2 % 2 % seulement
des contrats qu'ils ont signés avec des
pays européens où d'autres à travers le
monde ils ont promis de 800 millions de
doses se sont engagés sur 800 millions
2,2 ils en ont livré que moins de 20
millions
envie donc ça relativise aussi le sujet
je fais pas de polémiques géopolitique
sur ce sujet on reparle de la russie
tout à l'heure même si un narratif comme
on y géopolitique évident de la part de
la russie faut pas être naïf mais il ne
livre pas donc c'est peu produit et ça
n'est pas autorisé pour des raisons
scientifiques
je ferme cette parenthèse sur ce point
qui concerne la liste des vaccins parce
que dans le cas du passé ni terre je
crois que c'est un point important et
puis dernier point qui a fait l'objet
d'une discussion c'est dans ce cadre
sanitaire ce sont les questions de
solidarité internationale je n'y reviens
pas en détail vous le savez je viens
d'évoquer l'europe reste aujourd'hui
premier exportateur et premier donateur
de vaccins au monde peut-être je
l'espère rattraper dans les prochaines
semaines par les états unis qui
accélèrent leurs propres dons mais c'est
aujourd'hui l'europe qui avait que 90
millions de doses données dans le cadre
du mécanisme kovacs l'exportation
d'environ 300 millions de doses fournies
une large partie des besoins mondiaux et
l'on voit que ce n'est pas de la naïveté
mais aussi l'avait rappelé de l'intérêt
sanitaires bien compris puisque nous
sommes tous victimes des variants qui se
développent de par le monde parce que la
vaccination prend du temps beaucoup plus
de temps dans des pays qui ont moins de
capacité et moins de moyens financiers
nous renforcerons cela a été également
évoquée dans le cadre du g7 nos efforts
de solidarité internationale d'ici la
fin de l'année avec un engagement du g7
des pays du g7 de livraison d'au moins
500 millions de doses d'ici fin 2021
pour répondre à votre question sur
l'allemagne profite monsieur le
président
la chancelière a évoqué la question
britannique à ma connaissance elle n'a
pas demandé que toute l'europe et une
même mesure mais a fait part de son
inquiétude en raison de développements
du variant l'allemagne depuis le mois de
mai mme parce que là une politique un
peu différente de classement des zones
applique en effet une quarantaine
c'est l'équivalent notre zone orange qui
est plus systématique aux voyageurs
venant du royaume uni mais même s'il a
été parfois évoqué la presse la
chancelière merkel et les länder
puisqu'il faut un accord non pas
dégrader si je puis dire la situation du
royaume uni leur propre classification
et on a parlé d'une interdiction
d'entrer sur le territoire allemand de
la part des voyageurs britanniques
ça n'est pas le cas mais nous n'avons
pas d'indication que l'allemagne
décidera une telle mesure dans les
prochaines semaines quant à nous la
circulation du variant est la seule
raison pour laquelle nous continuons de
placer le royaume uni non pas en zone
verte comme sa situation sanitaire
l'ensemble pourra lui permettre mais en
zone orange avec donc même quand on est
vacciné obligation de tests au départ et
quand on a pas quand on n'est pas
vacciné motifs impérieux strictes pour
entrer sur le territoire donc ces
dispositifs sérieux que nous appliquons
au royaume uni pour cette raison et que
nous pourrons si cela était nécessaire
évidemment dégradés ou renforcée en zone
rouge si la circulation du variance se
propager encore au royaume uni comme
nous l'avons fait en début d'année pour
le variant anglais à l'époque voilà sur
les questions de santé je pourrais
revenir dans notre échange je peux être
trop long pour essayer de couvrir les
autres sujets puisque l'on parle de la
crise qu vidé de ses différentes
implications un mot sur la question
la dimension économique puisque a été
pas directement en lien avec le le coc
vide mais dans les suites de la pandémie
elle nous avons tenu les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement ont obtenu un sommet de
la zone euro
le vendredi matin de ce conseil européen
qui a été un sommet de premières
orientations après crise qui n'a pas
donné lieu à des décisions précises mais
les questions qui ont une foi n'ont pas
fait l'objet ici de débat ou de
décisions précises comme l'union
bancaire seront au menu des prochaines
des prochaines échéances de la zone euro
dans les mois qui viennent cela est
évoqué par les ministres des finances
lors de leur dernière réunion
cela a permis néanmoins de faire un
point sur les plans de relance puisque
au delà du conseil européen lui même il
y a une forte actualité sur ces sujets
vous avez rappelé que les choses
s'étaient accélérées la commission
européenne a procédé à ses premières
émissions de dette au mois de juin
moment nous prévoyons lors de notre
dernier échange c'est à dire début juin
après les ratifications par les 27
parlements des 27 états membres
40 c'est quelques parlements des 27
états membres et donc cela a permis
cette levée de dette qui a été je le
signale parce que je crois que c'est un
poids politique important
un succès donc un gage de confiance
aussi dans l'endettement et
l'investissement européen puisque la
demande de dette a été couvert a été
cette fois couverte par l'offre que les
investisseurs financiers ont proposé et
le taux obtenu par l'union européenne
pour cette émission commune se situe
entre le taux souverains français et le
taux souverains allemands
c'est à dire dans les tous meilleurs de
l'union européenne même meilleur que le
taux français pour cette première
émission on verra pour la suite donc
c'était prend un gage de qualité de
confiance très important cela permettra
pour être très concret après validation
des premiers plans de relance dont le
plan français par la commission
européenne la semaine dernière il faut
une approbation formelle des ministres
des finances dans quelques jours les
décaissements au cours du mois de
juillet la commission a stocké si je
peux le dire ainsi vingt premiers
milliards d'euros d'émissions de dette
fait au mois de juin pour assurer ses
premiers versements la première tranche
pour la france est prévue au taux de 5
milliards d'euros au titre des 40 dont
nous aurons le bénéfice sur la totalité
de la période 2021 2023 voilà pour être
précis sur ce point le prénom la
république a révoqué nous pour en
rediscuter l'idée que au delà de cette
relance il s'agit pas de faire cela le
relance européen et numéro deux en
avions parlé ou d'augmenter le plafond
les 750 milliards d'euros essayons déjà
de les dépenser utilement mais que à la
question d'un plan d'investissement de
long terme dans les secteurs
stratégiques ciblées comme le font les
américains sur la décennie qui vient
jusqu'à 2030 au moins matière de micro
processeurs de semi conducteurs de
technologies vertes et d'autres secteurs
d'avenir se pose et nous aurons ce débat
pas dans l'immédiat sol dans les
prochains mois probablement par le
nouveau gouvernement allemand sera aussi
installée au cours de la présidence
française de l'union européenne sur
l'investissement européen à long terme
et les moyens que nous avons de le
renforcer
j'entends avec ce que vous nous préciser
qu'en fait on est prêt à décaisser là au
niveau de l'union et ça doit arriver là
incessamment sous peu parce que on a eu
plusieurs dates mais finalement est-ce
qu'il ya une date qui est vraiment
formalise alors je dois vous dire un
jour exact ce mélo au cours du mois de
juillet nous aurons très
vraisemblablement une première tranche
de financement et je l'avais indiqué ici
même j'avais pris un petit risque et le
décalage est fait à quelques jours près
j'avais dit que le processus serait
terminé fin mai les derniers
ratification a eu lieu le 30 mai et
c'est le 1er juin que la commission a
lancé son processus d'émission donc on
est vraiment allé au plus vite que les
textes ne vous permettait et c'est cela
qui a permis au cours du mois de juin de
lever ses 20 premiers milliards d'euros
sur toute l'année c'est presque sans
doute même un peu plus si on prend
l'ensemble des besoins de trésorerie de
100 milliards d'euros que la commission
va lever sur les marchés et donc pour
être concret la première tranche combien
difficile en la france ainsi que
d'autres pays où cet été sera très
vraisemblablement décaissés au moins de
juillet une réunion des amis des
finances de mémoire le 13 juillet et
c'est la dernière étape de formalisation
le processus est assez lourd avant que
l'argent qui existent aujourd'hui soit
versée aux états membres
je saute un peu l'ordre des thèmes du
conseil européen pour parler du menu
international lui-même qui fut un menu
dans le menu extrêmement abondant et
riche je serais bref et vous pourrez
revenir dans les changes
outre un déjeuner qui a précédé le
conseil européen avec le secrétaire
général des nations unies monsieur vous
intéresse qui a été reconduit dans ses
fonctions il y a quelques jours il y a
eu de longs échanges sur la turquie sur
la russie est sûre à la demande de la
france la situation au sahel
le prêt à la république ayant souhaité
faire un point sur les derniers
développements dans la région
s'agissant de la turquie pour y revenir
nous sommes dans la ligne qui étaient
définis sur le fond au conseil européen
de décembre 2020 dont j'avais l'occasion
de rendre contre 2
rendre compte devant votre commission
qui consiste à renforcer la fermeté
européenne tout en étant ouvert au
dialogue mais en disant en quelque sorte
à la turquie à vous de voir l'attitude
que vous voulez avoir vis-à-vis de
l'europe ne sommes pas dupes
soit il ya des signaux tangibles et
durables d'apaisement et nous sommes
prêts à entrer en discussion sur l'union
douanière j'ai rassemblé sujets concrets
progressivement
soit il y à des provocations qui se
poursuivent ou se renforcent et ne
pourront évidemment que prendre des
mesures supplémentaires de rétorsion de
sanctions la turquie a donné quelques
signes d'apaisement ne faut pas
surestimer mais qui sont réelles au
cours des dernières semaines des
derniers mois notamment méditerranée
orientale en se réengageant dans un
dialogue bilatéral avec la grèce qui ne
produit pas encore de résultats
tangibles mais qui est un signal
d'apaisement sur chypre également même
si la dernière réunion à genève n'a pas
permis d'avancées substantielles mais
elle a créé je l'espère un climat plus
positif et c'est aux vues sans naïveté
encore une fois et sans que ce soit
définitif au vu de ce paysage légèrement
apaisées légèrement apaisé que l'union
européenne a accepté de commencer à
discuter d'un certain nombre d'éléments
je pense justement à l'union douanière
et dans ce contexte mais je souligne
vraiment la spécificité de ce sujet en
effet pas seulement pour la turquie mais
principalement pour la turquie
une nouvelle tranche de financement
pluriannuel à destination des réfugiés
prise en charge a été dans son principe
parce qu'il est ensuite une procédure
législative validé politiquement par le
conseil européen
c'est en effet pour la turquie 3
milliards d'euros qui sont en jeu d'ici
2024 et qui juge insiste mais transite
pas par le gouvernement turc mes soins
destination en général par une gestion
internationale des réfugiés pour leur
prise en charge car aussi vrai que
l'attitude de la turquie est condamnable
a beaucoup d'égards et nous n'avons pas
hésité à le dénoncer vous l'avez fait un
monsieur prises dans plusieurs reprises
à juste titre aussi vrai que cela reste
la situation il est exact aussi que la
turquie prend en charge près de quatre
millions de réfugiés sur son sol et qu'
il ya la geste humanitaire qui nous
par tient aussi de faire dans notre
intérêt d'ailleurs et c'est dans ce sens
que nous avons accepté que tous les
clients d'accepter le principe de la
poursuite de ce financement très
spécifiques
c'était deux tranches de 3 milliards
dans la ce qu'on appelle la la facilité
pour les réfugiés en turquie
est ce une tranche supplémentaire de 3
milliards sur la période 2021 2024
serait dans son principe acté elle doit
encore être discutée et votée par le
législateur européen
voilà le paysage donc ce n'est pas une
attitude en quelque sorte de récompense
je veux insister là dessus à travers ce
financement de la turquie même s'il y a
par ailleurs quelques signes
d'apaisement
c'est la poursuite d'une action qui
semble sur ce point spécifique justifie
sur la russie
nous sommes dans une début du débat si
je peux le dire ainsi
la chancelière merkel avec le prendre la
république
on souhaitait que l'on puisse
questionner les des outils dont les
européens collectivement font montre à
l'égard de la russie non pas pour avoir
une attitude conciliante affaibli mais
parce que nous voyons bien la difficulté
de trouver la juste mesure entre des
sanctions nécessaires parce que les
raisons qui ont poussé à l'adoption des
sanctions depuis 2004 demeure il ne
s'agit pas de les lever les amendements
franco-allemand qui ont été proposées au
conseil européen visé même à évoquer le
renforcement si la situation se dégrader
à nouveau mais c'est cet équilibre
difficile à définir en trouvant les
canaux d'un dialogue politique dialogue
politique ne veut pas dire soumission
naïveté désamorçage de nos sanctions de
nos mesures répressives mais c'est
l'intérêt collectif d'avoir aussi ce
canal européen la question des formats
et d'un éventuel sommet qui défrayait la
chronique bruxelloise n'était pas le
doubs le coeur des amendements qui ont
été proposées conjointement par la
france et l'allemagne lors de ce sommet
dans les conclusions du conseil mais
peut-être une perspective pour dire si
un homme politique pourrait y avoir des
formats a défini
deux rencontres entre les dirigeants
européens encore une fois sur une forme
que l'on définit ras plus tard et les
autorités russes nous ne sommes pas là
et je partage votre diagnostic monsieur
le président il faut toujours sur ces
sujets au delà même du fond et avant le
fond être extrêmement vigilant dans la
méthode et je le dis très sincèrement
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
publiquement
je pense que parfois la france comme
l'allemagne ont parfois donné le
sentiment je crois que ce n'était pas
l'intention mais donner le sentiment que
nous avancions sans tenir compte des
sensibilités de nos autres partenaires
et c'est l'intérêt collectif que de le
faire c'était pour ça que le président
s'était rendu plusieurs jours dans les
pays baltes en septembre dernier nous
devons je crois renforcer encore cette
attention et ça n'est pas que symbolique
à nos partenaires à la menace russe qui
pour eux comme pour nous tous mais pour
plus encore réelle presque tangible et
évidemment avoir en tête que tout geste
potentiel même conditionné même
sélective puisque c'était l'objet des
amendements franco-allemand à l'égard de
la russie doit être disputée
collectivement c'est d'ailleurs nous qui
avions demandé qu'on ait cette
discussion à vingt-sept à l'occasion du
sommet européen
nous aurons encore à le faire parce que
je crois que définir le bon équilibre
l'égard de la russie restera une forme
le gage heures pour l'union européenne
mais nous avons besoin en tout cas de
d'européaniser ce débat est de le
poursuivre sur le sel je serais bref
parce que le point que j'évoquais
consiste essentiellement pour le prix
dans la république a informé le conseil
européen de nos dernières décisions
orientation en rappelant que si le
format la nature de nos missions
évoluent être celle et ça n'était pas
une surprise complète puisque son option
de prix avait évoqué à plusieurs
reprises mais évidemment le nouveau
contexte malien
il ne s'agissait pas d'un désengagement
ni du mali ni du sel
et encore moins de la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans la région et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que c'est pour
l'information était important nous ne
pouvons pas demander avons partagé à de
nombreuses reprises à être plus soutenue
- seuls nous français au sahel et a
demandé donc une participation
européenne croissance qui petit à petit
se met en place et ne pas discuter
collectivement ou moins informés nos
partenaires de la situation et de nos
propres orientations et donc je le
signale à cette occasion nous avons
d'ailleurs réuni davantage de soutien
ces dernières semaines à la task force
takouba en particulier qui réunit les
forces spéciales sur des missions
difficiles et un pays comme la roumanie
s'est engagé aussi à nos côtés avec près
de 50
un contingent de 50 forces spéciales qui
complète à kouba et sept au total en
incluant la france maintenant dix pays
européens qui sont dans cette force
d'accompagnement voit que sur des
missions précises on arrive à convaincre
nos partenaires européens c'est
difficile c'est parfois long que
l'intérêt commun se joue là bas et que
c'est notre sécurité européenne que l'on
défend à travers une mission française
qui se réalise progressivement
un dernier point si vous me permettez
monsieur le président parce que là aussi
il a fait l'objet de il a fait l'objet
de beaucoup de discussions politiques et
médiatiques
c'est la question hongroise puisque ça
n'était pas prévu
une semaine avant le conseil européen
dix jours exactement le parlement
hongrois a amendé gouvernement hongrois
plus exactement a fait amender un projet
de loi qui était déjà en discussion et
qui a été voté avec une partie
extrêmement préoccupante puisque il y à
une assimilation explicite entre des
contenus pornographiques pédophiles et
des contenus des images homosexuels
cette assimilation est le coeur du
problème que nous avons soulevés à
l'égard de la loi hongroise
je l'occasion de m'exprimer le train de
la république s'est exprimé très
clairement à l'issue du conseil européen
je serai bref mais cela a fait l'objet
d'un débat long tendue au sein du
conseil européen ne pas être béat
d'optimisme mais le fait qu'il y ait une
prise de conscience est que pour la
première fois des leaders européens en
des termes très durs ont pointé du doigt
cette nouvelle dérive puisque il y en a
d'autres dans d'autres domaines en
matière d'état de droit de la hongrie
dans notre domaine de la pologne mais le
débat était là sur la hongrie atteste
cette sensibilisation européenne aux
questions de valeurs d'état de droit et
de respect des droits fondamentaux
j'insiste il ne s'agit ni de s'ingérer
dans la vie politique hongroise aucun
parlement de l'accepterai aucun
gouvernement de l'accepterait mais nous
touchons là des valeurs qui sont
inscrits de notre traité que nous avons
tous c'est un pacte fondateur européen
ratifié librement souverainement et nous
parlons ici de sujets graves qui ne sont
pas neutres et qui touche précisément
ces valeurs européennes
je le dis aussi l'occasion de le dire
publiquement
il ne s'est pas agi même s'il ya eu
quelques déclarations vive en ce sens de
fer entamé un processus de sortie ou
d'exclusion de la hongrie de l'union
européenne
ce n'est pas le sujet et ce serait une
forme d'échec pour la société hongroise
pour nous mêmes et il ne s'agit pas de
cela et comme le rappelle près de la
république à l'issue du conseil européen
il s'agit aussi de comprendre au delà
d'une loi aussi grave soit elle précise
celle que j'ai évoquée pourquoi un
certain nombre de dirigeants européens
se sentent habilité autorisé qu'ils en
fassent une forme de commerce politique
parfois à attaquer des valeurs aussi
fondamentales de notre pacte politique
européen se doit d'être interrogé sur
une défiance à l'égard d'un stand de
valeurs européennes qui ne faut pas
accepter mais qu'il faut aussi décrypté
pour essayer d'y répondre cela étant dit
le conseil européen était l'occasion
pour la présidente la commission
européenne avec un soutien très large
deux lancers d'indiquer le lancement de
procédures contentieuses à l'égard de la
hongrie qui pourrait se traduire par une
saisine de la cour de justice après
quelques étapes préalables avant la fin
de cette année voilà pour le compte
rendu sur ce point supplémentaire qui a
occupé longuement la table du conseil
européen jeudi et vendredi dernier et je
suis évidemment j'ai président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs aux
dispositions pour compléter ou ajouter
d'autres points merci monsieur le
ministre
comprendre peut-être la parole tout à
l'heure mais en tout cas là je voudrais
laisser la parole à mes collègues donc
il ya laurence harribey qui veut
s'exprimer depuis madame lagarde
on commence dans l'ordre allaient
laurence harribey merci président
merci pour cette présentation 4 4 4
question est très très rapide dans le
point 8 le point 7 et le point 8 du
compte rendu officiel du conseil sur la
relance économique
il ya une espèce d'ambiguïté dans le
point 7
on rappelle un petit peu les plans
nationaux et la nécessité d'une dune
d'une mise en oeuvre en respectant les
intérêts financiers de l'union c'est un
peu ce que je vous avais dit lors de mon
intervention
en avant le conseil on sent quand même
qu'on ne rendent dans un espèce de
l'exercice classique de semestre
européen avec le conditionnement
2 du plan de reprise par rapport un
certain nombre de principes mais en même
temps c'est en contradiction avec le
point 8 qui précise que le conseil prend
note avec satisfaction des grands
objectifs du sommet de lisbonne et du
plan d'action du sommet de porto par non
et du plan d'action qui surfe sur les
questions des droits sociaux et donc du
coup moi j'aimerais votre analyse là
dessus sur ce qu'il ya derrière et la
volonté réelle de l'union la deuxième
question est liée sur le point 10 du
compte rendu du conseil qui se satisfait
des progrès rapides en vue d'une réforme
mondiale de l'impôt sur les sociétés
dans le cadre du g20
moi je voudrais que vous nous disiez
parce que vous n'aviez pas répondu à
l'interpellation qui était la mienne
l'ordre de 7,2 cette séance avant le
conseil
est ce que on peut envisager un accord
intergouvernemental et non pas un accord
à l'unanimité qui est quelque part un
faux semblant
même si des questions de fiscalité on le
sait sont du domaine de l'unanimité on
pourrait avoir un travail sur la
coopération
voilà pour les deux premières questions
la troisième question est plus sur les
questions d'immigration fins de
migration pardon le dans le point 12,2
du rapport du conseil
on parle de plan d'action pour les pays
d'origine pour l'automne 21 et qui
doivent contenir des objectifs clairs de
mesures de soutien supplémentaires et
des calendriers
est ce que vous pourriez nous en dire
plus sur les idées directrices qui sont
qui sont demandez donc aux états et puis
la dernière question c'est le sait c'est
plus une appréciation ou une
interpellation sur le dernier point du
compte rendu du conseil concernant la
cybersécurité et les actes
la condamnation gentillette des actes de
cyber malveillance il est attendu des
propositions c'est un peu mince alors
que l'enjeu est quand même fondamental
sur l'union européenne qu'est ce que
concrètement la france va pouvoir
initier et il favorisé dans le cadre
dans le cadre européen
voilà merci
d'accord on prend part de questions
christine lagarde
oui merci je m'excuse déjà parce que
cette question sera un peu en marge du
conseil européen mais elle fait écho au
conseil pour le coup affaires étrangères
qui a suivi les discussions et vous avez
fait un large propos justement sur
toutes les questions relatives aux
affaires étrangères et vous pouvez vous
en douter ma question elle porte sur le
liban puisque dans le compte rendu de ce
que j'ai pu voir du conseil affaires
étrangères
des mesures ont été prises contre un
certain nombre de pays
je n'ai pas trouvé mention de discussion
ou de d'action sur le liban vous m'aviez
dit que ce sujet sera à l'ordre du jour
du conseil affaires étrangères
je pense que vous ne pouvez pas ignorer
que la situation là et quand même en
train de se tendre vraiment de manière
très forte dans ce pays donc alors
peut-être que vous pouvez pas tout nous
dire de ce qui s'est dit ou pas dit mais
là je pense ça serait intéressant de
savoir si au delà de ce qui s'est dit au
conseil européen dans les discussions
parallèles il ya eu des choses sur la
situation dans ce pays où dans la zone
proche orient merci très bien sûr madame
à cette crise arriver sur la dimension
sociale l'articulation semestre européen
je vais être clair qu'est ce qui est
prévu ou pas prévu dans la stratégie de
relance et de résilience puisque chaque
pays rohmer un plan national de relance
et de résilience nous l'avons fait au
moins 2 2 mais il a été approuvé par la
commission européenne la semaine
dernière
il n'y a pas de conditionnalité
il ya une procédure d'évaluation est
assez lourde et rappeler approbation par
la commission validation collective par
le conseil au niveau des ministres des
finances mais avait dit ainsi c'est
important il n'y a pas de droit de veto
d'un pays sur un autre ce qui aurait pu
entraîner évidemment des exigences en
termes de telle ou telle réforme qui
aurait pu conduire sans doute à un degré
de contrainte excessive et puis il n'y a
pas non plus une sorte de logique
stricte réforme contre argent pour être
très clair
néanmoins et nous l'assumons pour nous
mêmes une stratégie pour ça vient aussi
sur ce terme de relance et de résilience
ça ne sera pas seulement dépenser de
l'argent quand bien même celle d'argent
pour investir
ce sera aussi poursuivre ou utiliser ces
artistes et somme pour faciliter un
certain nombre de réformes dites
structures qui seront à définir adapté
dans ce pays mais il n'y aura pas une
forme de mécanismes professoral où la
commission européenne ou tel ou tel pays
au hasard au nord de l'europe viendra
expliquer qu'il faut faire une réforme
du marché du travail des retraites de
thèmes de tel aspect de l'économie mais
les pays de manière transparente le
projet national mais roland cette
résidence français et public évoque un
certain nombre d'éléments de réformes
que nous comptons faire de toute façon
on prend l'exemple de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage nous avons mentionné
dans le plan national de relance réside
en chacun pense ce qu'il en veut mais
nous n'avons pas lancé pour obtenir
l'argent européen ou parce qu'il y avait
ce débat européen et il y a deux
éléments qui sont s'être sens strict des
conditions pour la validation de ses
planques la france à a rempli mais nous
les avions d'ailleurs demandé c'est une
condition écologique
au moins 37 % des dépenses consacrées à
la transition écologique pour la france
et 50 % lorsqu'on nous avons soumis à
nos partenaires européens et au moins
20% nous avons fixé notre propre cible à
25 % de dépenses consacrées à la
transformation numérique développement
de la fibre investissements la
numérisation des entreprises autres
et donc ce sont les deux seules
conditions au sens strict qui sont
posées sur le plan social il n'y a pas
de il n'y a pas de de conditionnalité l
on peut trouver que c'est regrettable
dans un sens ou dans l'autre il n'ya pas
comme il ya sur le plan écologique ou
numérique un pourcentage de dépenses à
fixer sur le plan social il n'y a pas
non plus en sens inverse au titre de la
protection des intérêts financiers de
l'union européenne ne sorte d'intrusion
européenne dans nos réformes sociales
des années à venir il ya des exigences
de bonne gestion qui sont liées à tout
l'utilisation toute utilisation des
fonds européens d'arrêter ses classiques
est ce que on va avoir pour être clair
une forme de nouvelles logiques type
semestre européen austérité surveillance
précise des réformes est faible prise en
compte de la dimension sociale de
l'après crise je ne crois pas pour la
raison j'ai indiqué et aussi parce que
ce n'est pas une forme de coquetterie de
le mentionner effectivement points 8
depuis le sommet de porto même si elle
se met porto est fondé sur une
déclaration politique qui reste général
mais qui est associé est néanmoins les
partenaires sociaux lui toute l'europe
il y a un agenda social européen qui
prend un peu de substance
on a longtemps utilisé l'europe sociale
comme un paravent comme un slogan c'est
évident quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé ces deux trois dernières années je
crois qu'on aura un nouvel élan après
crise sur la réforme ultra est détaché
aujourd'hui sur la directive sur les
salaires minimums avec dans quelques
mois nous y pousse ont beaucoup une
proposition de texte sur les
travailleurs des plateformes de ceux qui
partout dans nos villes livre nos repas
ou ou d'autres activités qui sont très
peu encadré socialement cela sera soumis
à une hésitation en plein dans les
prochains mois je crois qu'il ya pas ni
de contradiction ni de l'hiérarchie mal
placée entre l'économique et les
réformes d'une part et la dimension
sociale d'autre part dans le stratégie
européenne de relance on est un peu plus
tôt dans un moment où je crois je les
dis on c'est terme déjà on a changé le
logiciel européen tant mieux sur ces
sujets sur les questions de fiscalité
internationale qui font leur parti un
peu de ce monde plus équitable d'après
crise que nous ayons de dessiner au
niveau multilatéral
il y aura un g20 finances les 9 et 10
juillet discussion à l'os et des oeufs
en ce moment et après et nous avons
effectivement deux obstacles à franchir
est ce que nous aurons un accord
international n'ont pas unanime mais
suffisamment large pour que cela ait du
sens et que l'accord à l'os et des
dessous et taxes soit trouvée je le
crois pas gagné mais je le crois parce
qu'il y est mais cette impulsion du g7
et dans quelques jours j'espère que g20
est ce qu'au niveau européen nous aurons
nous mêmes puisqu'il faudra transposer
cet accord international dans une
installation commune est ce que nous
aurons l'unanimité exigées en matière
fiscale
je le crois aussi en réalité parce que
nous avons fait pivoter le débat d'une
stricte taxation des entreprises
numériques vers une taxation plus des
multinationales lors des pays sont
exprimés contre 1 pour être très clair
l'irlande
c'est d'ailleurs le seul qui sait de nos
états membres qui s'est exprimé
explicitement contre cette réforme mais
avec je le dis amicalement une très
forte pression non seulement les
partenaires européens mais aussi de
l'allié américain pour que la position
ornaise évolué et donc le crois que
l'histoire n'est pas terminée
est ce que si on avait un blocage on
pourrait avancer à quelques-uns oui
c'est possible c'est possible
juridiquement en oeuvre des coopérations
renforcées en matière fiscale
on a essayé sur la taxe sur les
transactions financières on n'a pas
abouti ce stade en tout cas mais c'est
possible et donc là je crois qu'il ya
une obligation de résultat sur cet
accord international
pour le dire clairement pense qu'on peut
le dire pour la france et l'allemagne a
minima nous ne laisserons pas cet accord
international que l'europe a poussé les
américains ont débloqué n'ont pas créé
donc débloqué par là le changement de
position de monsieur maiden tant mieux
en début d'année on ne va pas casser
cette opportunité historique d'avoir une
réforme taxation de très grandes
entreprises internationales et donc vous
trouverons les voies et moyens de le
faire dans un format à déterminer je
souhaite évidemment que ça puisse se
faire au niveau de l'union européenne
parce que
je crois que partout et je dirais même
en irlande vois pas comment nos
concitoyens comprendrait que ce soit
l'union européenne où certains pays de
l'union européenne bloquant les autres
qui mettrait en danger
un accord international aussi important
et aussi juste ouf
mais il faut se préparer à toutes les
éventualités donc je réponds cette fois
plus précisément mais la sénatrice à
votre interpellation
vous avez bien fait de renouveler nous
avons cette boîte à outil qui permet
aussi d'agir dans des formats plus
restreint si cela était nécessaire sur
la migration le point 12 et le sujet sur
les plans de les plans d'action pour les
pays d'origine et de transit
c'est l'idée qui a déjà été développées
mais qu'on a objectivement jamais
vraiment mis en oeuvre collectivement en
tant qu'européens d'avoir ensemble une
négociation avec certains pays pour ça
qu'on parle de pays prioritaires
certains pays d'origine de transit pour
de manière offensive et défensive
parlant de le dire de manière un peu
brutale met plus de pression pour que
sur le phénomène d'immigration illégale
il y ait de leur part plus de
coopération
très concrètement cela peut passer par
l'aide que l'on verse qui peut être
renforcée sur la problématique
migratoire
il est indiqué au point suivant des
conclusions vous avez cité que c'est un
peu abscons mais que 10% des fonds le
développement européen seront consacrés
positivement c'est pas une sanction au
contraire une incitation à la lutte
contre les phénomènes migratoires
illégaux
une manière plus positive au soutien
aussi au développement local pour
limiter les phénomènes migratoires à la
racine
mais donc c'est cette idée là que l'on
au propre et à nizas attendent de
discussion qu'on a avec par exemple des
pays du maghreb
parce que il y à des pays je sais pas
quelle formule sera retenu mais je
souhaite qu'on explore par exemple cette
piste quand on parle de relations avec
la tunisie en exemple très concret il
est évident que la france a un rôle à
jouer et que nous pouvons le jouer dans
nos discussions avec le gouvernement
tunisien au nom de l'union européenne
parce qu'à la fin nous avons les mêmes
intérêts et finit là dessus il ya tout
cela si on se parle franchement qu'est
ce qu'il y avait à l'idée que celui de
développement c'est vrai pour les pays
d'origine mais pour les pays de transit
en particulier au nord de l'afrique
on sait très bien que vous ne pouvez pas
avoir une politique migratoire efficace
notamment la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale
si vous n'avez pas de reconduites et la
reconduite ça ne dépend pas
principalement de nous ça dépend des
laissez passer consulaires les fameux
que les pays d'origine ou de transit
accepte ou non de délivrer reconduit
quelqu'un quelque part à l'évidence et
donc avoir une pression collective
européenne sur un certain nombre de ces
pays qui sont les principaux si je peux
le dire ainsi pourvoyeur de flux et
croit une tactique une stratégie plus
exactement que nous n'avons jamais
vraiment su mettre en place au niveau
européen
c'est ça qu'il ya aussi derrière le
point que vous avez relevés sur les
cyberattaques vous avez raison ça a été
évoqué je n'ai pas précisément
l'introduction par la pologne qui a été
victime
cela a été un peu souligné dans notre
débat public et médiatique en france
d'une attaque probablement russe qui a
visé a révélé à ce temps de conversation
privée de responsables politiques haut
placés aux collaborateurs très proches
du premier ministre polonais je le
signale parce que celle il en va à
nouveau
malheureusement nous avons cela était
moins connu aussi une attaque contre le
système de santé irlandais sans doute de
même origine il ya quelques semaines et
donc on voit bien que
la menace n'a pas disparu et qu'elle
vise sans doute à envoyer des signaux de
pression des alertes aux différents pays
européens pour dire nous pouvons frapper
partout et tout le monde donc on ment
nous avons d'ailleurs des échéances
électorales ou d'autres enjeux
vaccination par exemple pour nous avons
besoin de systèmes d'information
sécurisés
nous avons encore très clairement cette
menace je les dis je le redis
malheureusement seul n'a pas avancé ces
dernières semaines mais nous avons en
matière de cybersécurité les mêmes
menaces mais aussi de les mêmes
capacités d'expertisé de très haut
niveau en europe
l'ansi en france d'autres agences
européennes sont de bon niveau et nous
aurions intérêt à voir non pas pour le
plaisir de créer des machins comme
aurait dit le général de gaulle mais
pour la renforcement de nos moyens
communs une agence européenne de
cybersécurité serait je crois
indispensable pour que notamment cogné
un processus électoral dans un pays on
puisse mobiliser des experts d'autres
pays comme on le fait en matière de
sécurité civile par exemple pour aider
et lutter contre des cyber attaques qui
se multiplient donc vous avez raison de
souligner que ce n'est pas un ça n'est
pas un point anodin même s'il a fait
l'objet d'assez peu de débats et de
cèpes de visibilité au conseil européen
pour répondre
massa triste lavabre sur le liban et le
débat du et le débat du conseil affaires
étrangères qui en fait avait précédé en
effet de quelques jours le conseil
européen on l'avait évoquée
le ministre gerry veulerie on l'a évoqué
lui-même au conseil affaires étrangères
en marquant sa très forte préoccupation
en évoquant la possibilité ou la
nécessité de sanctions et cette pression
que nous avons misé la prise de
conscience doit dire spontanée du
haut-représentant josette borel sur ce
sujet fait que c'est pas si une décision
sera prise car c'est un débat sensible
mais il y a la volonté européenne de
d'examiner de possibles sanctions dans
les semaines qui viennent et en tout cas
de maintenir la pression en élaborant
d'abord ce régime de sanctions pour
signaler aux aliments que nous sommes
prêts à le faire contre les acteurs
politiques qui demeurent les
responsables du blocage donc pour être
très clair sur ce point est bien été
mentionné par la france le haut
représentant travail à un pack est
possible de sanctions à notre demande et
nous continuerons à manier si je peux
dire la carotte et le bâton pour que ce
paquet de sanctions antennes soient
disponibles et sans trahir de grand
secret le le secrétaire d'état brigade
secrétaire d'état américain qui a
échangé avec jean yves le drian
il y a quelques jours a évoqué ou jean
yves le drian a évoqué plus exactement
ses sujets et la position américaine et
croit la même maintenir la pression
maximale n'écarter aucune option y
compris le sanction supplémentaire donc
ce sujet a bien été évoquée par la
france au conseil affaires étrangères du
21 juin pour maintenir une forte
préoccupation est plus qu'une
préoccupation une pression jacques
fernique qui rendrait bientôt là
oui merci sur le président le ministre
en question multiples ce n'est pas tout
j'ai pioché dans ce que j'avais prévu
donc effectivement vous l'avez évoqué la
loi homophobe en anglais en gris non qui
qui nécessite effectivement eu une
contre offensive européenne mais qu'ils
soient pas juste formel même si on sait
en termes très durs mais mais qu'ils
fassent en sorte que tous les habitants
des membres de l'union et droit au
respect de ses valeurs
deuxième point c'est ce n'était pas
exactement l'ordre du jour du conseil
mais c'est à l'ordre du jour européen
on a de la peine à décrypter la portée
exacte de l'accord informel provisoire
sur les règles de tarification du
transport routier de marchandises
[Musique]
qui semblent stabilisés en clair quelle
conséquence concrète pour notre pays
est ce qu'au delà des autoroutes déjà à
péage il devrait nous amener à terme à
la mise en place d'une contribution
poids lourds et et troisième point sur
la conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
j'ai participé à quelques semaines à une
réunion de l'agora strasbourg européenne
sur la question et s'il ya eu
effectivement un bon écho que rencontre
la démarche j'ai ceci dit peur que la
démarche lancée la machine lancée
parti sur sa propre logique s'illusionne
un peu sur sa capacité à susciter un un
vrai grand débat public
en gros comment élargir comment sortir
de la bulle des habitués du débat
européen et permettent une vraie plus
value et pour cela donner des signaux
aux citoyens de l'utilité du débat pour
obtenir des résultats
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
oui là aussi bon dans un débat post
conseil on a vu des conclusions quand on
regarde les conclusions et l'ordre du
jour on se demande si l'union européenne
et à bon escient n'est-elle pas en train
de passer dans une autre dimension
c'est à dire à l'ordre du jour beaucoup
de points concernant les relations avec
les états tiers
bien entendu le plan de relance très
liés à la pandémie de co vide et
peut-être que l'europe qui pendant
longtemps s'est focalisée sur elle même
et s'est concentré sur ses propres
politiques intérieures commence à
prendre en compte les interactions d'un
monde qui est de plus en plus complexes
et déstabiliser le cas de la politique
de la concurrence qui pendant longtemps
a fait la guerre aux subventions d'état
c'est pendant la période relativement je
dirais assoupli le fait qu'on ait un
plan de relance européen
particulièrement important s'est
finalement aussi des aides publiques qui
sont attribués au niveau européen avec
une coordination
mais surtout on se rend compte que
l'attractivité de notre continent qui
reste des plus riches est ce qui fait sa
puissance commerciale et économique
c'est le niveau de vie de sa population
aujourd'hui est très convoité la
commissaire européenne en charge de la
politique de concurrence la dame fait
hashtag disait récemment que les
investissements étrangers directs dans
l'union européenne en 2010 9 en tous les
cas représentait sept mille milliards
d'euros nous avons mis en place des
instruments pour nous préserver parce
que finalement lutte contre les aides
d'état à l'intérieur
on a pris des mesures concernant le
mécanisme de filtrage des
investissements étrangers et trouve
récemment je crois le 5 mai dernier la
commission a proposé à présenter une
proposition de règlement sur les aides
d'état extra-européenne
et il y a eu un rapport de la cour des
comptes européenne l'an passé en 2020
qui est passée un peu inaperçue mais qui
montre combien la chine est devenue un
acteur très important de ces aides
combien ça perturbe
je dirais la concurrence sur le marché
parce que ces aides à travers des
entreprises publiques d'états vers
d'autres entreprises publiques ou
privées ce cumul voir contrecarre les
aides organisé au niveau européen donc
il ya eu cette présentation
elle est passée un petit peu inaperçu je
crois que c'est effectivement une
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important pour contrôler ce qui se passe
sur notre marché
la présentation qui a été faite était
assez sibylline on ne parlait pas de
cible pas du tout c'est pas du tout le
rapport de la cour des comptes
européenne
on parle pas du tout de la chine je
comprends les précautions diplomatiques
mais on manque un peu de précision
justement sur les cibles l'impact
recherché
et puis tout ça a été déposé devant le
conseil et le parlement européen
qu'est-ce qu'on n'envisage comme
procédure je dirais de ratification de
cette de cette de ce règlement et qu'est
ce que la france compte faire par
rapport àça l'appuyer ce qu'il faut
renforcer certains points en tous les
cas monsieur le ministre on est un petit
peu en dehors du débat du conseil
européen mais je crois que c'est un
sujet et une décision qui est importante
en tous les cas pour assurer notre
autonomie notre stratégie
je dirais de souveraineté européenne
si vous me permettez je vais commencer
là dessus mais je reviens sur les
quelques questions de center fernique
oui je pense qu'il ya un changement de
modèle qui était encore très incomplet
parce que l'on clair mais qui a
néanmoins infiltrer les esprits bon sens
du terme pour répondre plus précisément
au point que vous soulevez sur ce
règlement qui est en gestation
il me paraît très important s'il va au
bout et c'est notre souhait cette
présentation par madame b styger devrait
intervenir très vite il est un
changement assez fondamental de quoi
s'agit-il vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
sénateur il s'agit de non seulement de
transposer à septembre d'exigence
légitime est très stricte sur nos
propres interdiction de subventions aux
entreprises étrangères et donc de dire
que dans un marché public dans une
opération d'acquisition partielle ou
totale de l'entreprise européenne
si vous avez ça ne vise pas qu'un pays
mais très concret un investisseur
chinois
une entreprise chinoise qui participent
six toujours le cas mais si elle reçoit
des subventions on peut le démontrer
dans son propre pays pour être capable
de baisser ses coûts sur notre marché
nous serons capables d'empêcher cette
opération d'exclure cette entreprise
spécifiquement durablement de la
candidature des marchés publics par
exemple donc c'est un vrai changement
enfin regardez le texte dans tous ses
détails mais cette idée qu'on recrée une
équité concurrentielle tout simplement
est absolument essentiel on peut pas
avoir les règles de concurrence le plus
dur du monde
trop dur certainement pour que nos
propres entreprises ne soient pas
capables de combattre sur le plan
international à l'extérieur en
particulier et en plus nous autoriser
les autres qui sont subventionnées
parfois par leur propre gouvernement ou
par des structures publiques à venir sur
notre marché
c'est très intéressant parce que
d'ailleurs je crois pour ceux qui sont
très attachés la concurrence qui est
parfois encore un dogme est une
référence pour beaucoup de nos
partenaires européens ils le comprennent
un pays comme les pays bas est très
favorable à ce mécanisme anti subvention
étrangères parce que c'est justement la
préservation d'une concurrence il en
faut une juste concurrence et donc à
sept le nombre de pays attaché à une
concurrence équitable comprennent
parfaitement la nécessité d'un tel
mécanisme est par ailleurs nos
entreprises vous le savez comme moi ou
mieux que moi me disent très
régulièrement
il faut pas plus mais qu il soit trop
compliqué il faut pas que les mailles du
filet soit trop l'âge on va regarder
tout ça mais c'est un vrai changement
comme le contrôle des six dans des
investissements des pays tiers les
secteurs stratégiques
même si le système n'est pas encore très
mordant au niveau européen ce sont des
changements fondamentaux du logiciel
européen
je souhaite que ça aille plus vite comme
vous mais c'est une avancée importante
sur les questions de que vous déposez
monsieur le sénateur fernique d'abord
sur la loi hongroise pour y revenir mais
en quelques mots les dix nous avons une
prise de conscience politique c'est déjà
beaucoup
une pression politique beaucoup plus
forte qu'auparavant c'est important et
c'est indispensable ça n'est pas
suffisant et dans notre capacité
d'action
on est aujourd'hui je le dis sincèrement
limité pour une raison que j'avais
indiqué je crois précédemment qui me
paraît la raison fondamentale c'est que
peut-être avons-nous été collectivement
neige mais on ne pensait pas qu'un pays
adhérer à l'union européenne pour
ensuite reculer
donc on est extrêmement exigeant dans le
respect de valeurs fondamentales ou
d'éléments de manière plus large qui
constitue l'état de droit aussi bien
dépendance de la justice l'indépendance
des médias que
la non-discrimination élémentaire avec
les pays c'est un long chemin qui
veulent rentrer dans l'union européenne
et une fois qu'on est rentré
paradoxalement on ne vérifie plus comme
si ça allait de soi le respect de ses
valeurs on voit que ça ne va
malheureusement pas toujours le soin je
veux pas rajouter au procès il vient
d'instruire le procès bon sang c'est
très grave et on a peu d'outils le
règlement qui a été votée en fin d'année
dernière le règlement conditionnalité
est très important parce que pour la
première fois il crée un lien qu'on peut
discuter intellectuellement mais qui a
le mérite d'être efficace entre le
bénéfice des fonds européens et le
respect de l'état de droit la sanction
peut être les suspensions un certain
nombre de financements européens
je suis très transparent on le sait ce
règlement européen il ne couvre que
certaines violations l'état de droit
principalement manque de lutte conte
insuffisance de lutte contre la
corruption manque d'indépendance de la
justice
c'est important mais ça ne couvre pas
tout sa couronne le cas qui nous occupe
donc je crois que nous aurons et toute
pression politique est utile à cet égard
besoin de revoir ce règlement je ne
cache pas que ça prendra un peu de temps
pardon non non ça passe pas par un
traité ça peut se faire à la majorité
donc c'est pour ça aussi que ce
règlement est précieux absolument
et donc comme souvent en europe on a
planté la graine de ce règlement qu'il
faut la première fois permet de prendre
des sanctions financières à la majorité
n'ont pas l'unanimité et en revanche il
faut élargir son champ pour traiter des
cas comme celui qui nous occupe à
l'égard de la hongrie sur la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe
je partage votre idée encore maintenant
faut-il qu'on passe aux actes de sortir
de la bulle
et comme je l'avais dit je crois au
sénat de ne pas faire un débat pour les
professionnels de la profession
je me range dedans on a déjà de quoi
débattre
l'important c'est d'écouter des
critiques des remarques de personnes qui
ne sont pas forcément d'ailleurs hostile
à l'europe mais soit ne comprennent pas
soit ne sont pas informés ne
s'intéressent pas c'est évidemment
vous apprends rien le plus difficile
donc on essaie de le faire par
différents exercices aussi je suis très
franc la conférence telle qu'elle se
déploie aujourd'hui au niveau
institutionnel et j'étais présent à
strasbourg
non seulement pour le lancement formel
avec le prime la république mais le 19
juin pour les premiers débats elle se
montre décevant pour l'instant c'est pas
du tout une fatalité on va se battre
pour qu'elle soit plus ouvert plus
active et pour l'instant on assiste dès
succession de monologues point de très
franc qui ne débouchent pas sur une
discussion de fond
donc si c'est ça la conférence on aura
raté une grande opportunité on n'y a
aucune fatalité à ça et on appris
j'espère qu'on et multipliera deux
initiatives que je rappelle rapidement
une qui consiste à faire une
consultation en ligne mais ciblée sur
les jeunes de 15 à 30 ans on vise 50
mille jeunes par une start up française
qui s'appelle mike points en qui a déjà
travaillé pour diverses institutions et
qui a la capacité par sa son démarchage
encadré évidemment sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les sites internet
fréquentés par les jeunes d'aller à
mener vers son site et versa
consultation les questions qu'elle pose
sur l'europe au moins au moins cinquante
mille jeunes c'est l'objectif qu'on a
fixés contractuellement 10 6 mois de
septembre pour identifier un stand de
critiques ou de points positifs que ces
jeunes voient dans l'europe en france et
puis nous aurons aussi 11 septembre dans
chaque région des panels citoyens de 50
personnes par région - avec un
prestataire et des gares en le priant du
sénat désignera d'ailleurs un garant
pour vérifier le processus est robuste
et transparent qui sont représentatifs
en termes d'âge de genre de catégories
socioprofessionnelles et qui pendant
deux jours et demi c'est un long
processus délibératif dans chaque région
disputeront le sujet européen
identifieront des critiques des réformes
a poussé dit-il nous aurons une synthèse
public évidemment
probablement pour la mi-octobre synthèse
nationale qui nourrira la contribution
française au delà des débats qui se
tiendront certainement dans votre
semblait certainement l'assemblée
nationale aussi pour se nourrir donc
cette contribution française à la
conférence soit bien alors il faut
essayer par tous canaux je mesure bien
la difficulté d'ouvrir le jeu si je peux
le dire ainsi sur 7 sur 7
sur cet exercice un mot sur l'accord
eurovignette il a fait l'objet de
l'accord pour être clair et peux pas
vous en dire plus aujourd'hui car nous
regardons la façon dont nous devrons
transposer la directive des tours aux
vignettes l'accord du 16 juin
il n'y a pas d'obligation dans tel ou
tel pays de revoir les mécanismes de
taxation dès lors que le réseau central
est déjà couvert par des péages ce qui
est le cas chez nous sur les autoroutes
concédées
donc nous regarderons les conséquences à
en tirer mais pour être clair il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas d'obligation nationale
à cet égard voilà je crois avoir à
répondre aux différents points de ces
deux questions
pardon voilà donc sommes à la moitié
oui alors on va prolonger parce qu'on
avait dit jusqu'à fin juillet mais on va
prolonger sans doute pour couvrir l'été
young
merci merci président le ministre veut
venir sur un point que vous avez
effleuré mais mais pas pas développés
qui est l'union bancaire et l'union des
marchés de capitaux
j'ai ma petite idée sur le sur le fait
que au fond il n'y a pas eu de
développement et nous avions comme l'a
rappelé le président rappela nous avons
présenté la semaine dernière à une
communication et un avis entre autres
sur la surveillance bancaire par la
banque centrale européenne je pense
qu'on a dû vous là la faire parvenir
on a plutôt bien avancé en matière d'
union bancaire sur la surveillance et
sur la résolution mais il nous reste le
troisième le troisième pilier que nous
connaissons qui est la garantie la
garantie des dépôts sur lequel on on
patine depuis de nombreuses années c'est
à dire la possibilité d'avoir un fonds
de garantie des dépôts bancaires qu'ils
soient communautariser et en particulier
il ya une réticence plus qu une
réticence de l'allemagne en la matière
le projet a encore été si j'ai bien
compris
reportée dans le calendrier le projet
edison que c'était ça la décision ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus et
quelles sont les perspectives ou les
chances union des marchés de capitaux
alors là c'est encore pire puisque on
avance quasiment pas et c'est pourtant
un point essentiel puisque c'est ce qui
devrait permettre de faire circuler
l'epargne et donc les investissements
entre entre nos pays et pour l'instant
chacun reste sur son sur son épargne et
veut surtout pas que cet ehpad haye
profiter aux voisins et pour l'instant
on voit pas on voit pas de perspectives
il y à court terme mais à moyen terme je
suis un peu un peu triste un peu
d'expérience
et enfin dernier point un peu lié mais
pas tout à fait sur le volet financement
bancaire avec les anglais
quand cadre du brics its avait été
laissée pieusement de côté avec beaucoup
de sagesse mais enfin il reste quand
même beaucoup de problèmes à résoudre
sur les équivalences des chambres de
compensation et c est ce que il ya une
négociation qui avance avec les anglais
là dessus je j'attendais mon ma ration
de questions étaient toujours présents
près je souhaiterais revenir rapidement
sur un point sur lequel je souhaiterais
avoir plus que de précision 7.5 des
conclusions du conseil européen
alors que récemment lors d'auditions au
sein de la mission d'évaluation des
effets du co vide mission sénatoriale
ont été rendues les conclusions d'une
étude de la mairesse laisse entendre
sans trop de contestations au moins
scientifique la perspective d'une
quatrième vague
à l'automne prochain sur la base aussi
de l'analyse qui font apparaître des
différences de traitement et donc de
sortie crise des entreprises européennes
en fonction des états qui sont
évidemment dans une situation pas tout à
fait égal les unes envers les autres
à l'issue de cette crise je voulais que
vous puissiez une présentée nous
préciser la position française défendue
lors de ce conseil européen pour se
préparer à une réaction plus collective
sur la base du retour d'expérience que
nous avons eu des trois principales et
des propres ainsi dès les trois
premières vagues de co vide et être
certain que la notion de résilience on
est effectivement une notion pas
simplement d'affichage mais effective
pour se préparer à d'éventuelles
conséquences de cette quatrième vague
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour répondre aux
questions de richard yong sur le sur
l'union bancaire et l union des marchés
de capitaux et ça me permet en effet de
compléter ma réponse trop rapide au
président rapin bon pour être très clair
sur l'union bancaire on a fait des
progrès importants et on a débloqué 1
point et est encalminée de longue date
en 2018 s'est mis en place cette année
c'est ce qu'on a appelé en mauvais
français le bac stoppe pas celui du
break site mais l'autre qui était le
filet de sécurité alimentée notamment
par des contributions des banques qui
s'est mis en place plus tôt que prévu
puisque l'époque les allemands ne
voulaient pas bougé de la date qui a été
fixée de mémoire à 2024 et nous avons
réussi a avancé de près de trois ans
parce que la réduction des risques
c'était l'argument allemand d'être
sceptique sur le rythme de réduction des
risques notamment des prêts dès que les
prêts douteux dans les bilans bancaires
nous avons réussi à anticiper cela parce
que nous avons démontré que la réduction
des risques étaient finalement rapide et
nous avons maintenant l'étape à franchir
qui est la garantie des dépôts et 10
vous l'avez rappelé pour être clair avec
le gouvernement allemand termine son
mandat et ses fonctions qui sera sans
doute en poste en pratique jusqu'à la
fin de l'année à peu près nous
n'arriverons pas à franchir une étape
supplémentaire
il y a eu des discussions au niveau des
ministres des finances de nouveau
l'allemagne c'est à ça cela quoi vous
faisiez je crois que monsieur le
président tout à l'heure a fait une
ouverture sur l'idée d'un mécanisme de
garantie dépôt mais en posant des
conditions inacceptables pour la france
mais en fait pas seulement pour la
france pour beaucoup de pays dont
l'italie et l'espagne
parce que les contributions qui aurait
pesé sur les banques françaises auraient
été disproportionnée donc on veut
évidemment mécanisme de mutualisation on
veut aussi que la contribution à ce
mécanisme
c'est notre devoir de défendre aussi le
secteur bancaire français de manière
équitable qui est un secteur comme vous
le savez de d'excellence au niveau
européen et un avantage économique
certain nous ne pouvons pas accepter des
conditions qui ont été je pense de
manière tactique défendu à ce stade par
nos amis allemands
et donc c'est un débat qui
malheureusement traîne sitôt sur
d'autres aspects ou au premier étage de
l'union bancaire nous avons fait des
progrès importants et qui ne reprendra
pour être concret que au début de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne et avec les nouvelles
autorités allemandes en espérant mais je
suis relativement confiant là dessus que
il n'y aura un état d'esprit plus
constructif après les élections sur
religion les marchés de capitaux et
suivi de dossier de longue date c'est
extrêmement frustrant parce que tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que c'est
une des grandes faiblesses européenne le
moins d'accord pour avancer en théorie
et on ne trouve pas la clé du déblocage
pas fait mauvaise comparaison mais c'est
un peu comme sur le pacte migratoires on
sait qu'on a un équilibre intelligent
qui est proposé en terme de textes
législatifs mais on n'arrive pas à
débloquer parce que l'objet est trop
gros politiquement et donc je crois et
c'est le travail qu'on doit faire
notamment le ministre des finances d'ici
la présidence française de l'union
européenne et notamment aussi avec les
nouvelles les autorités allemandes qu'on
reprenne par quelques objets concrets ne
sais pas vous dire lesquelles mais
est-ce que c'est l'harmonisation du
droit des faillites qui est une dont le
morcellement est un vrai problème de
compétitivité européenne est ce que
c'est un autre objet par lequel on
commence parce que il faut qu'on découpe
si je puis dire le puzzle en petits
bouts sinon ce restera l'objet de
colloques et de constat de blocage
plutôt que un chantier d'avancées
concrètes et précises et on sait que sur
le marché unique puisque c'est un
élément aussi important que le marché
unique à l'époque dès débuts de l'agenda
de jacques delors on l'a pris avec un
agenda précis objet par objet avec une
date une priorité donnée à tel ou tel
texte il faut je crois faire la même
chose sur yon les marchés de capitaux je
ne sais pas vous dire aujourd'hui quel
est le
la clé d'entrée exact mais il faut qu'on
casse ce chantier très vaste en morceaux
plus digeste ans le droit des faillites
pour ça que je signalais et un est un
bon outil le ministre avant vous un
conduit aussi aux sénateurs arnaud avant
les questions d'actualité je voulais
savoir et vous n'êtes pas obligé de me
répondre parce que je sais qu'il ya des
tractations qui sont secrètes entre
guillemets mais quel serait le taux
moyen que la france pourrait accepter
enfin pourrait intégrer dans ces seuils
d'acceptabilité dans la discussion avec
les allemands pour la participation des
banques françaises à la globalité c'est
que c'est quelle quelle est la vôtre
partie parce que si vous permettez
monsieur le président je ne peux pas
citer le chiffre pour les vérifier aussi
avec notre ministère des finances mais
pour éviter de mettre une cible trop
petit mais on peut et on peut le jeu
peuvent offrir l'instant d'éléments à
l'issue d'auditions si vous voulez être
on a fait ensemble simulation le taux
acceptable pour la france mais
clairement les propositions allemandes
deux mois dernier n'était pas n'était
pas acceptable
un peu plus de 30 fois je crois au delà
de 30 sur les questionnements sur la
résilience et le son que l'on commence à
tirer paragraphe 5 que vous avez cités
de la pandémie il ya le rapport de la
commission européenne qui restent assez
générales sur ce que devrait être une
robe de la santé est ce qu'on devrait
mettre derrière un concept de résilience
et post crise le temps nous est compté
mais je voulais quand même citer
quelques éléments qui me semble
ça rejoint à peu près les propositions
de la commission être concret est
prioritaire si on veut tirer les leçons
de cette crise d'abord on a avec
quasiment rien sur aucun domaine en
matière de santé j'en vois trois qui
sont à mon sens d'évidence les données
les équipements et la recherche médicale
les données parce que c'est d'abord le
thermomètre enfin là on commence par là
nous n'avions aucune base de données
commune à tous les sens du terme
vous vous en souvenez le début de la
crise quand il y avait des comparaisons
dans la presse ou dans différents
travaux plus ou moins fiables sur le
nombre de victimes le nombre de morts de
la pandémie
on ne savait pas on ne sait toujours pas
exactement le fera à travers les
enquêtes de surmortalité en réalité
comparer la situation sanitaire précise
d'un pays européen à l'autre comme
dirait pas forcément le plus urgent
m'enfin c'est très important pour les
outils de réponse à la crise je prends
un autre exemple en matière de données
si vous ne savez pas voir une
classification communes des zones à
risque à l'intérieur de l'europe pour
l'extérieur de l'europe dont l'incidence
terrassa s'est améliorée évidemment au
début de la crise ont été fort démunis
on ne sait pas avoir des mesures
coordonnées de l'autorisation ou
l'interdiction de voyage d'un
d'ouverture ou de fermeture des
frontières internes et donc avoir un
outil de pilotage
nous avons un centre européen il
s'appelle le cdc objectivement la crise
a montré les grandes limites pour ne pas
dire les flagrantes carences nous devons
avoir un mécanisme sérieux de partage de
l'information en matière sanitaire
cela implique je le dis aussi de bouger
nos propres réflexes et nos propres
bureaucratie national parfois pour qu on
partage les données fiables en matière
de situation sanitaire ce n'était pas
l'habitude les administrations
sanitaires nationales
soyons clairs deuxième fois les
équipements je l'évoqué tout à l'heure
en faisant la comparaison en matière de
protection civile sur la cybersécurité
je crois qu'on a là un modèle qui avait
d'ailleurs été porté à l'origine par
michel barnier
quand il était commissaire en matière de
protection civile européenne qui
fonctionne bien en mutualisation de
moyens de lutte contre les incendies on
les renforce mois on doit faire pareil
en matière sanitaire on a commencé à le
faire entre les deux vagues de
l'épidémie il faut qu'il me réserve
européenne d'équipements médicaux de
kits de test de blues de gand devrait ce
pirate heures de tout ce qu'on veut pour
faire face à une crise pour ne pas être
dépendant et en compétition les uns avec
les autres comme on l'a été au début de
la crise et troisième point c'est sans
doute le plus important pour innover et
être capable de répondre à une future
crise sanitaire quelle qu'elle soit
c'est que nous avons manqué de capacité
d'innovation et de prise de risque la
vraie différence avec les américains n'a
pas été au début de la campagne
vaccinale dans la négociation des
contrats le nombre de doses achetées de
stern n'achetait plus que les américains
on a eu quelques problèmes de livraison
mais c'est pas ça le coeur du sujet le
coeur du sujet c'est quand les
américains ont été capable via la barre
d'un américaine de mobiliser au mois de
mars 2020 15 milliards de dollars pour
financer évidemment ensuite avec des
priorités de livraison mais d'abord pour
financer la dernière phase de
développement de vaccins croire en des
technologies auxquelles les européens
collectivement croyez-moi objectivement
les rênes messages etc
il y a une capacité de prise de risque
mais qui a été solide et trébuchantes
beaucoup plus importante qu'en europe
et là je crois que c'est un cas qui
prouve une valeur ajoutée européenne
potentiel c'est plus utile d'avoir une
agence sur ce point européenne qui
finance des recherches médicales
urgemment face à une crise d'une manière
plus prospective parce qu'on ne va pas
faire ces efforts en doublon français
allemand italien espagnol et sans doute
d'ailleurs nous n'aurions pas les moyens
de le faire donc là je crois
pragmatiquement qu'il ya un vrai beau
projet européen comment et serra
effectivement c'est l'agent ce qu'a
proposé la commission européenne sur le
modèle de la barre d'un pour faire très
simple parce que ça marche
en l'occurrence ne nous faisons pas trop
nos cerveaux mais lady aussi dans
l'hémicycle autre jour le projet rat est
bon mais il est trop petit et trop lent
pour hitler
et donc c'était d'ailleurs l'objet des
annonces du prix en la république et en
matière de santé nous devrons investir
nationalement et au niveau européen
beaucoup plus dans ses capacités de
financement de la recherche médicale et
l'innovation c'est la résilience est un
concept plus large mais je crois que
s'il ya un manque européen dans la crise
ça n'est pas dans ce qu'on a réussi à
faire ensemble qui est le cas lors de
l'achat des vaccins ça j'y crois
profondément c'est de là dans cette
carence précise qu' on l'a trouvé et
qu'on doit y remédier en tirant les
premières leçons de la crise et la
commission l'évoquent
mais le fait avec ira mais on doit
augmenter très significativement les
quelques 150 à 200 millions d'euros que
la commission envisage de débloquer pour
ra je n'ai pas de chiffre magique à
définir mais enfin je parle des 15
milliards d'euros américain on est
clairement sur un ordre de grandeur de
dix ou cent fois plus par rapport à ceux
qui évoquent aujourd'hui la commission
open est alors pardon bien sûr dans leur
foi basique a pris plusieurs fois
ensemble exemple du paracétamol on
retrouvera notre capacité de production
on a appris dans la crise que la
première condition de tout ce compte on
discute souveraineté autonomie
stratégique c'est la capacité à produire
et la capacité industrielle
[Musique]